♪ ♪
"BLEPORPP PRESENTED BY FanDUEL.
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO GIVE YOU
A COMBINED RUSSELL WEST BROOM
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
ERIN DOLAN IS GOING TO GIVE YOU
POINTS.
GREG OIFOR
IVORY IS GOING TO N
THE WARDROBE AND I WILL GRAB
REBOUNDS AND KEEP IT MOVING.
MY NAME IS CABBIE RICHARDS MANY
YOU ARE GNGMI FROM THE BAY AREA
MR. G, GREG IVORY.
BACK IN DECEMBER ABSOLUTELY
NOBODY WOULD HAVE PREDICTED THAT
THE NEW YORK KNICKS WOULD BE IN
THE PLAYOFFS AND THE DEFENDING
NBA CHAMPIONS, THE LOS ANGELES
LAKERS, WOULD BE AGONIZING IN A
PLAY-IN TOURNAMENT.
HERE WE ARE.
EVERYBODY HAS A PREDICTION, BUT
THIS IS WHY WE PLAY THE GAME.
TONIGHT WE'RE ASKING YOU, WHO
WILL SCORE MORE POINTS
HEAD-TO-HEAD, JULIUS RANDLE OF
THE NEW YORK KNICKS OR ANTHONY
DAVIS OF THE LOS ANGELES LAKERS?
TO QUOTE THE GREAT KOBE BRYANT,
ANTHONY DAVIS PUT ON HIS BIG-BOY
PANTS AGAINST THE PHOENIX SUNS
ON SUNDAY AND HE CARRIED THAT
TEAM.
SO G MONEY, ARE WE GETTING SOME
EAST COAST LOVE IN THE COMMENTS
OR SOME WEST COAST LOVE IN THE
COMMENTS FOR THIS SPECIFIC
MATCHUP?
>> CABBIE, LET ME TALK TO ALL OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS,
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS.
I EITHER MEET EAST COAST, WEST
COAST LOVE.
YOU KNOW THE WEST COAST IS THE
BEST COAST.
>> I MEAN, SLOW DOWN.
COME ON.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT I AGREE
WITH THAT.
>> I'LL LET THAT BE KNOWN.
>> SERIOUSLY, MAN.
>> LET IT BE KNOWN.
CABBIE, YOU'RE NOT FROM THE EAST
COMPANIES.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU'RE FROM UP NORTH.
>> YEAH, YEAH, TORONTO IS EAST.
>> NO, I'M JUST MESSING WITH
YOU, BRO.
I'M JUST MESSING YOU WITH YOU.
ERIN, WE KNOW YOU ARE FROM
PHILLY.
ARE YOU LEANING EAST COAST IN
RANDLE OR ROCKING WITH THE BEST
SIDE, THE WEST SIDE IN A.D.?
>> I'M ACTUALLY GOING WITH
ANTHONY DAVIS.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO STEP UP,
OF COURSE, WITH LeBRON JAMES OUT
FOR THE GAME.
I WAS ORIGINALLY GOING WITH
JULIUS RANDLE BUT IT WAS BEFORE
LeBRON, I FIGURED HE WOULD TAKE
POINTS AWAY FROM A.D..
BUT RANDLE HAS BEEN QUIET, 24
AGAINST THE SUNS, 14 AGAINST THE
NUGGETS IN THE LAST GAMES.
A.D. FINDING HIS STRIDE SINCE
THE INDUSTRY, DOMINANT
BACK-TO-BACK PERFORMANCE, 32
AGAINST THE SUNS AND 46 GUEST
PORTLAND SO I'M RIDING WITH A.D.
>> THERE WERE 45 CHECK MARKS IN
THAT ANSWER, ERIN DOLAN.
WELL DONE.
BOTH DEFENSES ARE IDENTICAL AND
BOTH FRANK VOGEL AND TIM
THIBODEAU ARE GREAT TACK
INITIALANS.
A HALLMARK OF RANDLE'S GAME IS
SCORING IN ISOLATION.
THE LUCKY LEFTY LOVES THAT
ISOLATION.
HE SCORED THE SECOND MOST POINTS
IN THE ISOLATION AND HE FLOATS
WITH TRIPLE-DOUBLE IN MOST
GAMES.
WHO ON THE NEW YORK KNICKS IS
GOING TO GUARD A RESURGING
ANTHONY DAVIS?
HE FEELS THE PRESSURE OF THE
MOMENT, THERE'S NO JAMES TONIGHT
SO I THINK ANTHONY DAVIS WILL
DELIVER ANOTHER 30-POINT
PERFORMANCE.
GIVE ME A.D. TONIGHT AGAINST THE
KNICKS IN THE HEAD-TO-HEAD
MATCHUP.
G-MONEY, WHERE IS THE AUDIENCE,
EAST COAST, WEST COAST?
WHAT DO WE HAVE FOR TONIGHT?
>> CABBIE, ERIN, PEOPLE THAT ARE
NEW TO THE SHOW, THIS RIGHT HERE
IS CALLED THE HANDY, DANDY iPAD.
THIS IS WHERE YOU GUYS WILL BE
WINNING YOUR HOODIES.
CABBIE, ERIN, I AM IN THE
COMMENTS.
STARTING IT OFF I HAVE ANG322.
SAID, YES, SIR, WHAT IS GOODIE,
FACTS, MARTIN, BEST COAST.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE EAST
COAST.
>> YES.
>> THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT JULIUS
RANDLE.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE WRONG COAST, BUT
FORTUNATELY YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU.
I GOT -- HOLD ON.
THESE ARE JUST MOVING SO FAST.
I GOT MARTIN.
MARTIN SAYING EAST COAST,
ROCKING WITH -- HE'S ROCKING
WITH JULIUS RANDLE OF THE EAST
COAST.
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
I DON'T SEE TOO MANY WEST COAST.
LAST ONE, CLASSICMANSTEVEN, WEST
COAST, YES, SIR.
WEST COAST, YES, SIR.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU, CLASSIC MAN
STEVEN, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
ALL RIGHT.
THE HANDY DANDY iPAD IS STILL
UP.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, ARE YOU
LEANING WEST COAST WITH A.D. OR
EAST COAST WITH JULIUS RANDLE?
>> OKAY.
>> THAT'S A LONG SIGH, BRO.
>> I'M WEST.
I'M WEST TO THE DEATH OF ME, BUT
ON THIS OCCASION I'M GOING TO
ROCK WITH JULIUS RANDLE IN THE
PLUS MONEY HERE.
HE'S BEEN BALLING.
HE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY BALLING
THIS YEAR, BUT MY REASONING IS
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THE KNICKS
LATELY, AND I SEE THE BALL IN
HIS HANDS ALMOST ON EVERY
POSSESSION.
I'LL TAKE MY CHANCES THERE WITH
THE PLUS MONEY.
BALL IN JULIUS RANDLE'S HANDS ON
ALMOST EVERY POSITION, THE GUY
IS AVERAGING 23 AND 10.
HE HAS BEEN OFF, HE'S BEEN SLOW
RECENTLY.
HE'S BEEN SLOW AS FAR AS SCORING
POINTS, BUT HIS COACH, HIS COACH
GAVE HIM A LITTLE PICKUP TO THE
MADE YA' TODAY.
HE GAVE HIM A LITTLE CONFIDENCE.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH JULIUS
RANDLE ON THE PLUS MONEY.
>> HE ALSO PROBABLY WILL PLAY 45
MINUTES.
TOM THIBODEAU RUNS HIS PLAYERS
TO THE GROUND.
LISTEN, HEY, DON'T SLEEP ON
DEREK ROSE AND R.J. BARRETT AS
ALSO CARRIED THAT LOAD.
I THINK, ERIN, YOU AND I WITH
THE A.D. PICK IT LOOKS GOOD.
AS THE GREAT ONE ONCE SAID, YOU
MISS 100% OF THE SHOTS THAT YOU
DON'T TAKE.
THE ONE THING ABOUT THE
THREE-BY-TWO THAT IS IN COMMON
WITH THE GREAT WAYNE GRETZKY IS
THAT IT IS THE GREATEST BET IN
THE GAME.
TODAY IS THREE-BY-TUESDAY.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS MADE IN FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME.
LAST WEEK WE TOOK IT IN BROOKLYN
VERSUS DALLAS AND IT CASHED LIKE
THAT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YEP.
>> EASY.
>> ON THE FRONT LINE WITH --
>> LOOK AT THIS BALL MOVEMENT.
THIS IS JUST BEAUTIFUL.
>> OUT TO GRIFFIN.
>> THE BEST SHOOTER OF THE GAME,
JOE HARRIS.
MONEY!
LOVE THAT.
>> STARTING LINE-UP.
>> THANK YOU, JOSH RICHARDSON,
ON THE WING.
>> AND FOR DALLAS --
>> BOTH LEGITIMATELY,
LEGITIMATELY THE FASTEST THIS
BET HAS EVER CASHED.
THE FIRST TWO SHOTS OF THE GAME
WERE THREE-POINTERS.
COUNT THAT, EASY MONEY.
TODAY WE POSTED --
>> THAT WAS EASY, CABBIE.
>> NO DOUBT.
>> MY BAD, MY BAD.
>> NO, NO.
>> WE WERE ON THE LIVE WHEN THIS
HAPPENED, WE WERE ON THE LIVE
AND IT HIT LIKE WITHIN A MINUTE.
WE WERE ALL JUICED ON LIVE.
IT WAS LIT.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TAP IN TO THE
LIVE TODAY.
WE WILL DECIDE WHAT GAME WE'RE
RIDING WITH, BUT TAP IN TO THE
LIVE TODAY.
THREE-BY-TWO HIT IN LESS THAN A
MINUTE.
I DON'T THINK YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND IT.
IT WAS LEGENDARY RIGHT THERE.
>> DID YOU RUN DOWN THE STREET
LAST TIME?
>> NO, WE'RE ACTING LIKE WE'VE
BEEN THERE BEFORE.
>> OKAY.
YOU ARE BARRY SANDERS HANDING
THE TOUCHDOWN, THE FOOTBALL BACK
TO THE REFEREE BECAUSE BARRY
SANDERS IS LIKE, I HAVE BEEN
HERE 150 TIMES.
>> EXACTLY.
>> SO TODAY WE POSTED A POLL ON
TWITTER, WHICH THREE-BY-TWO WILL
CASH TONIGHT, MIAMI VERSUS
BOSTON, LAKERS VERSUS THE
KNICKS.
THERE ARE THE ODDS.
LET US PLEASE SEE THE RESULTS.
WHEW!
THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
50/50, EVEN SPLIT.
EAST COAST, WEST COAST, 50%.
OH, MY.
I DON'T EVEN -- I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT TO DO IN THIS
SITUATION.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN HERE BEFORE.
GREG, WHO DOES THE ARMY THINK IS
GOING TO CASH THIS BET?
LIKE DUNCAN ROBINSON AND JASON
TATUM IN THE EAST COAST GAME OR
JULIUS RANDLE AND KYLE KUZMA IN
THE LATE GAME ON TNT, WHAT DO
THEY THINK?
>> CABBIE, I HAVE NO IDEA, BUT
LET ME ASK THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO GET CREATIVE WITH
THIS ONE.
I NEED EAST COAST OR WEST COAST
GIFTS IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
YOU GUYS, GIVE ME GIFTS.
EAST COAST, WEST COAST,
DEPENDING ON WHICH GANG YOU ARE
RIDING WITH.
OBVIOUSLY MIAMI/BOSTON IS EAST
COAST.
NEW YORK/L.A. IS THE WEST COAST.
YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW WHICH WAY
ARE YOU GUYS RIDING.
>> THAT'S A TRICKY ONE.
>> A LITTLE GEOGRAPHY OUT THERE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> WHAT GIFTS DO WE WANT TO SEE?
>> THE GAME IS IN L.A.
>> YEAH, BUT DO WE WANT TO SEE
THE BEACH IN L.A., SOUTH BEACH,
MIAMI, DO WE WANT TO SEE
LEPRECHAUNS LIKE THE BOSTON
CELTICS' LOGO?
>> THAT'S A GOOD ONE, THE
SHAMROCKS.
>> I LOVE YOUR EXAMPLES, CABBIE.
WE WILL LEAVE IT UP TO THE
PEOPLE.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> THEY'LL GET SO CREATIVE.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO GET SO
CREATIVE.
ERIN.
>> YEAH?
>> ERIN, TALK TO ME, WHICH
THREE-BY-TWO DO YOU THINK WILL
CASH TONIGHT?
IS IT MIAMI/BOSTON OR IS IT
NEW YORK/L.A.?
>> STICKING WITH THE EAST COAST
GAME, MIAMI CELTICS FOR THE
THREE-BY-TWO TO CAST.
DUNCAN ROBINSON SHOOTING 40%
FROM THE THREE-POINT LINE, KE
KENDRICK NONE.
I THINK THEY CAN COME OUT AND
START SHOOTING RIGHT AWAY AND
HAVE THIS CASH.
>> I WANT TO SEE SOME D.J.
KHALID OR RICK ROSS GIFTS IN THE
VIBE.
LIKE WE'RE TAKING THIS -- I MEAN
THE GAME ISN'T IN SOUTH BEACH,
BUT IT IS MIAMI/BOSTON FOR ME.
SAD NEWS OUT OF BOSTON THAT
JALEN BROWN'S SEASON IS OVER
WITH A WRIST INJURY.
HE ALSO HAD AN ANKLE INJURY.
SO THAT VOID, THAT VOID IN
PRODUCTION IS GOING TO HAVE TO
BE FILLED IN PART BY EVAN
FOURNIER AND MARCUS SMART.
SINCE THE CELTICS WERE MOLLY
WHOPPED ON THEIR HOME COURT IN
FIRST HALF BY MIAMI IN THE LAST
GAME, 79 POINTS IN TWO QUARTERS,
I THINK THE CELTICS PLAY WITH
SOME URGENCY.
SO THAT'S MARCUS SMART, KEMBA
WALKER, EVAN FOURNIER, THOSE
GUYS WILL GET IT DONE FOR
BOSTON.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, HEY, IF WE
GET A LITTLE KENDRICK NUNN
THREE-POINTER OR DUNCAN ROBINSON
THREE-POINTER, THIS THREE-BY-TWO
IS GOING TO CASH.
>> YEAH.
>> GIVE ME MIAMI/BOSTON, AND
DEFINITELY GIVE ME SOME D.J.
KHALID GIFTS IN THE COMMENTS.
G-MONEY.
>> CABBIE?
>> YEAH.
>> THEY GOT SO CREATIVE IN THE
COMMENTS, IT IS LIKE SUPER
FUNNY.
I GOT RYAN RAY.
I MEAN HE GOT THE D.J. KHALID
GIFT.
WE ALL KNOW D.J. IS FROM THE
EAST COAST, FROM MIAMI.
SO, THEREFORE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
HE IS ROCKING WITH YOU GUY'S
PICK, MIAMI VERSUS BOSTON.
I ALMOST SEE RICK ROSS, MY GUY
SHAQUILLE OATMEAL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
WE HAVE MIAMI'S FINEST IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> THAT'S AN IMMEDIATE FOLLOW TO
ME, SHAQUILLE OATMEAL?
THANK YOU.
>> SHAQUILLE OATMEAL, CABBIE.
IT IS LIT.
IT IS SO LIT.
TWO OF MAN'S PICKS, I DON'T
KNOW -- THAT'S WILL SMITH!
IT IS WILL SMITH IN THE GIFTS.
>> WELCOME TO MIAMI, YEAH.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> WILL SMITH.
THEY'RE GETTING REAL CREATIVE,
CABBIE.
I GOT PALM TREES, BAY AREA TABS
WITH PALM TREES.
L.A., PALM TREES.
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE IN
THE COMMENTS, CABBIE.
IT LOOKS LIKE --
>> WHICH GAME DO YOU WANT?
LIKE THE TWITTER AUDIENCE IS
LOCKED 50/50.
THE COMMENT SECTION SEEMS MORE
EAST COAST THAN WEST COAST, BUT
WHICH GAME DO YOU PERSONALLY
WANT TO LOCK IN, G-MONEY?
>> IT HURTS ME TO SAY THAT,
CABBIE, BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID
I THINK I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
THE EAST COAST GAME AS WELL,
MIAMI VERSUS BOSTON.
>> ALL IN BUSINESS.
>> YEAH, WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT
ON THAT ONE.
LET ME NAME PLAYERS THAT WILL BE
ON THE COURT DURING THIS GAME.
DUNCAN ROBINSON.
TYLER HERRO WILL BE ON THE
COURT.
WE GOT JASON TATUM.
WE GOT -- WHO ELSE?
MARCUS SACRED HEART, KEMBA
WALKER.
THREE-POINT SHOOTERS, I CAN KEEP
GOING, IF YOU WANT ME TO,
CABBIE.
LIKE KENDRICK NUNN.
WHO ELSE?
>> I'M GLAD YOU DIDN'T SAY JIMMY
BUTLER.
>> MAYBE --
>> THE DRAGON JAM.
>> WAIT.
JIMMY BUTLER.
>> YOU CAN'T SAY THE DRAGON, THE
DRAGON COMES OFF THE BENCH, AND
THAT'S TOO -- THE DRAGON IS OFF
THE BENCH IN LIKE THE SIX-MINUTE
MARK.
>> BUT YOU NEVER KNOW.
WHAT IF SOMETHING HAPPENS EARLY?
>> FINE, FINE.
>> COME ON.
IT IS VIBES, BRO.
BAD VIBES.
>> LISTEN, FOR GOOD VIBES MAKE
SURE YOU CHECK THE BR BETTING
SOCIALS TO GET THE LINK TO THE
THREE-BY-TWO FROM FanDUEL.
ONE OF THE BENEFITS SURROUNDING
THE DRAMA OF THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT THIS SEASON IS THAT
WE HAVEN'T HEARD THE PHRASE
"LOAD MANAGEMENT."
THAT'S REALLY BECAUSE 20 TEAMS
ARE VYING FOR EITHER PLAYOFF
SEEDING OR THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT.
THE STRATEGY TO REDUCE TANKING
HAS WORKED, EVEN THOUGH LeBRON
JAMES AND LUKA DONCIC AREN'T
FANS OF THE FORMAT, BUT 20 FAN
BASES ARE FANS OF THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT FORMAT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LATEST ODDS
FOR THESE FIVE TEAMS TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS, CHARLOTTE HORNETS,
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS,
SAN ANTONIO SPURS, THE WIZARDS
AND THE PACERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I JUMPED OVER
THE PACERS IN THE MIDDLE THERE.
DE'MONTREZ, BONE YUS, IS LIKE W
ABOUT US?
NO YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE LEADER IS GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS AT MINUS 110 AND THE
LONGEST ODDS ARE THE SAN ANTONIO
SPURS WHO SEEM TO BE CRUMBLING
RIGHT NOW.
G-MONEY, A MONTH AGO DULUCA DON
SIFF WAS QUOTED AS SAYING I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT.
YOU PLAY 72 GAMES TO GET IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND MAYBE LOSE TWO
GAMES IN A ROW AND YOU ARE OUT
OF THE PLAYOFF, I DON'T SEE THE
POINT IN THAT.
G-MONEY, WHERE DOES THE AUDIENCE
STAND AND WHERE DO YOU STAND ON
THE PLAY-IN GAME?
>> CABBIE, I WILL GET TO WHERE I
STAND A LITTLE BIT LATER.
BUT LET ME ASK THE AUDIENCE.
LET ME ASK YOU GUYS, HEY, GUYS,
ARE PLAY-IN GAMES A GOOD IDEA?
DO YOU GUYS THINK THAT THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA?
I KNOW BRON SAID THAT SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO BE FIRED FOR THESE
PLAY-IN GAMES.
>> SOMEBODY NEEDS A RAISE.
>> I KNOW STEPH, LIKE -- YEAH,
YEAH.
THEN I KNOW STEPH KIND OF
CLAPPED BACK AT A QUESTION,
LIKE, IF YOU GUYS PLAYED THE
LAKERS, HE KIND OF MADE FUN OF
IT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK 30 IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE LAKERS.
BUT I KNOW THE LAKERS MIGHT BE
WORRIED ABOUT 30 IN THE PLAYOFF
GAME, BUT I -- I MEAN IN A
PLAY-IN GAME.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, ERIN, WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE?
THE COMMENTS ARE COMING IN, BUT
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THE PLAY-IN
GAME?
>> I LIKE THE PLAY-IN GAMES.
I THINK IT GIVES AN INCENTIVE
FOR TEAMS TO AVOID TANKING,
OBVIOUSLY MAKES IT MORE
COMPETITIVE.
I JUST FEEL LIKE IT IS REALLY
CONVENIENT FOR LeBRON TO COME
OUT AND SAY THESE COMMENTS AS,
OF COURSE, THEY HAVE THE NUMBER
SEVEN SEED IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE STANDING SO THEY
DON'T WANT TO PLAY IN THE
PLAY-IN ROUNDS.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY MAY HAVE TO,
BUT HAD HE SAID IT AT THE
BEGINNING I WOULD HAVE RESPECTED
BUT OBVIOUSLY NOW IT IS
CONTROVERSIAL SINCE HE MIGHT BE
PLAYING IN THE TOURNAMENT.
>> I LOVE THE PLAY-IN TOURNAMENT
AS WELL.
I'M WITH YOU.
I LIKE CHARLOTTE TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS, MOSTLY BECAUSE BOSTON
IS MISSING A HUGE PIECE OF THEIR
TEAM IN JALEN BROWN.
LaMELO BALL HAS BEEN PLAYING
AMAZING.
TER
TERRY ROGIER IS IN THE TOP TEN
UNDERRATED OR UNAPPRECIATED
PLAYERS IN THE NBA.
HIS CLUTCH NUMBERS ARE GROSS.
SCARY TERRY PLAYING AGAINST HIS
OLD TEAM BOSTON?
I'M THERE FOR THAT.
GIANT CONTAINER OF POPCORN AND
AN ADDITIONAL BAG OF DORITOS 'S
BECAUSE I'M GETTING FAT ON MY
KAVANAUGH WAT
COUCH WATCHING THAT IF IT
HAPPENS IN THE PLAY-IN SCENARIO.
THE HORNETS I BELIEVE WERE 124
ON THE BOARD.
G-MONEY, WHICH PLAYOFF TEAM ARE
YOU SEEING THE MOST GIFTS IN THE
COMMENTS AND WHICH TEAM ARE YOU
LOOKING TO GET IN?
>> CABBIE, I SEE A LOT OF -- I
SEE A LOT OF "NOs" FOR THE
PLAY-IN GAME.
I ALSO SEE THE WARRIORS IN THE
COMMENTS, OBVIOUSLY I MEAN I SEE
THE WARRIORS.
I SEE THE LAKERS IN THE COMMENTS
AS WELL.
I SEE LAKERS.
NO, THEY'RE ALREADY IN, BUT,
YEAH, I DON'T KNOW WHY THE
LAKERS ARE IN THE COMMENTS.
>> TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
THEY COULD LOSE AGAINST THE
WARRIORS AND POTENTIALLY LOSE
AGAINST THE WINNERS OF THE
GRIZZLIES AND SPURS.
THERE'S A CHANCE, IF THEY LOSE
TWO GAMES IT IS A WRAP FOR BRON,
A.D. AND COMPANY.
>> SO I WILL GIVE THAT PERSON A
HOODIE THEN.
>> OKAY.
>> KENNA RACY 98, SHOUT OUT TOO.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
NO PLAY-IN GAME.
BYE, WHAT A GIFT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CLASSIC MAN STEVEN SAYS, YEP,
BETTER MAN DESERVES TO BE IN THE
EAST PLAYOFFS THAN THE CELTICS,
MAN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, CLASSIC
STEVEN.
K-POTS IS COMING OUT OF NOWHERE
WITH THE CHARLOTTE HORNETS GIFT.
>> IS THAT LANCE STEVENSON
CHARLOTTE HORNETS GIFT?
>> THAT WAS LANCE.
>> LANCE TO MAKE THEM DANCE.
MY TAKE IS THE WARRIORS, MAN.
I SAID IT LAST WEEK, ERIN, AND I
KNOW YOU ARE NEW TO THE SHOW,
BUT ONE THING, I DON'T LIKE TO
REALLY SWITCH UP MY BETS.
>> YEAH.
>> LAST WEEK THEY WERE PLUS
MONEY.
THIS WEEK THEY'RE MINUS 110.
IF YOU WERE ON THE TRAIN LAST
WEEK, YOU WOULD HAVE HAD THE
PLUS MONEY, BUT JUST COME ON,
COME ON.
HOP ON THE TRAIN NOW.
IT IS OKAY.
TAKE THE MINUS 110.
I'M TELLING YOU GUYS WHAT THE
LOCK IS.
HEY, I WANT TO SEE BRON VERSUS
30 IN THIS PLAY-IN GAME, MAN,
CABBIE, BECAUSE I REALLY FEEL, I
REALLY FEEL BRON DON'T WANT
THOSE PROBLEMS.
BRON DON'T WANT THOSE PROBLEMS.
TEAMS, STEP TEAM IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, WE JUST NEED
DIFFERENT COMMENTS.
TEAM STEPH, TEAM BRON IN THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
>> ERIN, SORRY, WE DIDN'T GET
YOUR PICK.
WHICH TEAM?
YOU WERE ON WASHINGTON LAST
WEEK, HAVE YOU CHANGED YOUR
MIND?
>> I'M STICKING WITH WASHINGTON.
LAST WEEK WE SAID IT WAS PLUS
184, IT MOVED DOWN TO PLUS 124.
IT MOVED OFF THE BOARD FOR A
COUPLE OF DAYS AND THEN WENT
BACK UP.
WE KNOW BRADLEY BEAL IS NURSING
A HAMSTRING RIGHT NOW, BUT AS
LONG AS HE IS HEALTHY, HIM AND
WESTBROOK, HE STOLE THE SHOW
LAST NIGHT.
I THINK THEY'RE A GREAT DUO THAT
CAN GET IT DONE.
OBVIOUSLY IT ISN'T TO KNOCK YOUR
WARRIORS, BUT I WOULDN'T WANT TO
BET THEM SHOULD THEY HAVE TO
PLAY LeBRON JAMES AND THE LAKERS
TEAM OBVIOUSLY IN THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT.
>> BUT, ERIN, NOW THAT RUSSELL
WESTBROOK HAS SET THE RECORD FOR
THE MOST CAREER TRIPLE-DOUBLES,
HOW DO YOU THINK HE IS GOING TO
PERFORM NOW?
IT IS LIKE THAT HUGE BURDEN OR
THAT GOAL HAS BEEN REACHED.
>> EXACTLY.
I MEAN, HONESTLY, EVEN BETTING
INTO THAT MARKET, IT IS MINUS
400, AT LEAST YESTERDAY IT WAS,
FOR RUSSELL WESTBROOK TO HAVE A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
IT IS NOT A GREAT VALUE BETTING
ON IT.
I THINK EVENTUALLY IT WILL COME
TO A POINT, HE HAS THE RECORD,
HE WAS CHASING IT, SO MAYBE OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF GAMES.
I COULD BE WRONG.
HE WILL HAVE TO STEP UP TOMORROW
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, WASHINGTON
NEEDS THE WINS TO MAKE SURE THEY
STAY IN THE NUMBER TEN SEED IN
THE EASTERN CONFERENCE
STANDINGS.
BUT OVERALL IT COULD CONTINUE,
BUT IT IS NOT GREAT VALUE WHEN
BETTING IT AT THIS POINT.
>> GOTCHA.
SO YOU HAVE FAITH IN THE BRODIE?
>> YES.
>> BRODIE!
>> OKAY.
WELL, I KNOW THAT LAST WEEK YOU
HAD FAITH IN THE OTHER BRODIE
WHO IS NEXT TO YOU, BUT,
G-MONEY, IT WAS A DISASTER!
IT WAS DO-DO PIE, HIS ATTEMPT AS
A SAME-GAME PARLAY AS OFFERED BY
FanDUEL.
CAN WE LOOK AT THE TICKET AND
THEN GIVE YOU 15 SECONDS TO
EXPLAIN YOURSELF.
>> OH, NEVER MIND.
>> THAT'S SO MANY Xs.
IS THAT A TREASURE MAP?
>> I MEAN.
>> 0 FOR 5.
>> HEY.
HEY, HEY, HEY, WE HAD A BAD DAY.
>> IT HAPPENS.
IT HAPPENS, IT HAPPENS.
>> YEAH.
THANK YOU, ERIN.
>> YOU HAVE SOME SUPPORT HERE IN
THE GROUP CHAT.
>> LAST WEEK -- NO, NO, NO, WE
ARE ALLOWED TO ROAST EACH OTHER.
LAST WEEK I TOOK AN "L" AND
TONIGHT I BOUNCED BACK IS THE
BIG SEAN LINE.
BUT, BRO, LIKE YOU HAVEN'T GONE
0 FOR 5 EVER, I DON'T THINK,
UNLESS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
COLLEGIATE BASEBALL CLEAR.
>> EVER.
EVER.
NOT EVEN IN BASEBALL.
NO, I DON'T THINK I WENT 0 AND
5.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
>> POSITIVE.
POSITIVE.
>> YOU ARE BOUND TO BOUNCE BACK
THEN.
YOU HAVE TO GET JUMPING.
>> WHAT ABOUT A GOOGLE SEARCH?
>> YOU SEE THE GOOD VIBES RIGHT
THERE COMING THROUGH -- YOU
KNOW, THE MONITOR.
>> THE SUNSETS ABOVE YOU.
>> AND THROUGH THE STREAMS.
YEAH, SHOUT OUT TO YOU, ERIN.
SEE, CABBIE, TAKE A PAGE OUT OF
HER BOOK.
BRING IN ALL TYPE OF GOOD VIBES.
>> HEY, BRING BETTER VIBES WITH
SAME GIVEAWAY PARLAY, MY DUDE.
COME ON.
>> I GOT YOU, BRO.
LOOK HERE.
>> WHAT GIEMSAME ARE YOU GUYS -
>> HEY, IF YOU DO NOT KNOW, HEY,
THE SPECIAL GROUP OF PEOPLE, IT
IS MY SQUAD, THE WINNERS-ONLY
SQUAD.
I HAVE TO TAP IN WITH THE HEAD
HONCHO.
I HAD TO TAP IN WITH THE HEAD
DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD WEEK LAST
WEEK, BUT IT IS OKAY LIKE BIG
SEAN SAYS, WE BOUNCE BACK.
IN THIS WEEK WE ARE BOUNCING
BACK WITH DODGERS, MAD DODGERS.
HE HAS HELPED ME WITH THE SAME
GAME PARLAY.
SHOUT OUT TO MY GAD MAD DODGER.
>> SALUTE, MAD DODGER.
>> START IT OFF WITH DUNCAN.
STARTING IT OFF WITH DUNCAN.
DUNCAN ROBINSON, GO GET TEN.
>> OKAY.
>> GO GET TEN, DUNCAN.
THAT'S ALL I NEED YOU TO DO, IS
JUST GO GET TEN.
THREE THREES, GO GET FOULED,
MAKE A FREE THROW, MAYBE TWO,
MAKE IT EASY.
THEN CALL IT A DAY, BUT, DUNCAN,
GO GET TEN.
MOVING ON, CABBIE, THIS IS YOU.
I TOLD THEM, HEY, WE NEED A
CANADIAN CONNECTION WITH CABBIE.
HE'S LIKE, I GOT YOU, G.
TRISTAN THOMPSON.
>> SALUTE.
SALUTE, TT.
THERE WILL BE NO TRISTAN
THOMPSON SLANDER HERE.
ZERO.
>> GO GET NINE-AND-A-HALF
REBOUNDS, GET TEN, 11, 12, 13,
MAKE US FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
WE'RE TAKING THE OVER IN HIS
REBOUND TOTAL.
MOVING ON, JASON TATUM.
WE JUST GOT THE UNFORTUNATE
NEWS, MY GUY JALEN BROWN GOING
DOWN FOR THE YEAR.
THAT IS OKAY.
TATUM REALIZES THAT THE TEAM
MUST BE ON HIS BACK.
HE'S PUTTING THE TEAM ON HIS
BACK, AND IT IS STARTING
TONIGHT.
NEED 30, JASON.
NEED 30.
MOVING ON, BAM.
>> BAM?
>> BAM ANTETOKOUNMPO.
>> 30 PLUS?
>> HE LIKES TO GRAB THE
REBOUNDS.
NO, NO, SIMMER DOWN THERE,
CABBIE.
>> LOTS OF OVER.
>> ALL OVERS.
>> LOTS OF OVERS, YEAH.
>> HEY, YOU KNOW THAT BAM IS
LIKE -- HE'S A PLAYMAKER NOW,
RIGHT?
LIKE HE DOES -- HE DOES PLAY
CENTER TECHNICALLY, BUT MY GUY
LOVES TO PASS THE ROCK AND LOVES
TO SHOOT A GAME-WINNER A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO.
THIS EIGHT AND A HALF, IF
TRISTAN THOMPSON IS GETTING YOU
EIGHT REBOUNDS, THAT IS EATING
INTO THE SHARE THAT HE IS GOING
TO GOBBLE UP.
GO AHEAD.
>> BAM, BAM USUALLY GRABS AT
LEAST A COUPLE OF OFFENSIVE
REBOUNDS.
HE PUTS IT UP, GETS IT BACK,
PUTS IT UP, GET IT BACK.
DO THAT TWO OR THREE TIMES,
WE'RE AT SIX, HE'S A BIG MAN,
GRAB THREE AND THEN WE'RE THERE.
>> THAT MIGHT BE THE ONE THAT
GETS YOU.
THAT MIGHT BE A RED X ON THE
TICKET.
>> WE'LL SEE.
>> WHAT ELSE YOU GOT?
CLOSE IT DOWN?
>> ANOTHER BAD VIBE FROM CABBIE.
IT IS OKAY.
WE'RE GETTING USED TO IT.
ANYWAY, JIMMY BUTLER!
>> JIMMY BUCKETS.
>> I LIKE IT.
ALL PLAYER PROPS.
>> GO GET ME SEVEN, GET ME SEVEN
ASSISTS, YES, OVER
SIX-AND-A-HALF ASSISTS, JIMMY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
BE A PLAYMAKER.
THROW THE BALL TO BAM, A COUPLE
OF ALLEY-OOPS, FIND DUNCAN,
MAYBE GOREN, YOU KNOW, TYLER.
BE A PLAYMAKER, JIMMY.
THAT'S IT RIGHT THERE.
PULL UP A TICKET.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> PLEASE.
>> I FEEL LIKE I WANT TO GO BET
THIS RIGHT NOW.
>> WOW.
>> OKAY.
>> 23-TO-1, THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
THIS IS A LEGIT TICKET RIGHT
HERE, G-MONEY.
>> YEAH, THIS IS AWESOME.
>> THIS IS A LEGIT TICKET.
ERIN, WHAT DO YOU --
>> OH, SO NOW -- WHOA, GUYS.
>> -- DO YOU HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
THOUGHTS ON LIKES?
>> MY MAIN POINT IS OBVIOUSLY
LAST WEEK NONE WERE HEADING IN
THE PARLAY, BUT IT WAS MORE OF
THE FUN ONE.
OVERALL I FEEL LIKE IT IS SO FUN
BECAUSE IT IS PLAYER PROPS.
THIS IS A GREAT ONE.
YOU HAVE TO DO PLAYER PROPS FOR
THE SAME GAME ON FanDUEL.
IT IS THE MOST FUN.
>> IT IS THE MOST FUN.
SO, G-MONEY, GOOD LUCK, SIR.
GOOD LUCK.
BEFORE WE GO, THIS IS OUR LAST
SHOW BEFORE THE REGULAR SEASON
ENDS AND WE KICK OFF THE
PLAYOFFS.
THE PLAY-IN TOURNAMENT GOES FROM
MAY 18th TO MAY 21st.
SO IT HAS BEEN A LONG SEASON
WITH A BUNCH OF TWISTS AND
TURNS.
SO WE'RE ASKING THE QUESTION,
"WHAT TEAM OR PLAYER HAS COST
YOU THE MOST MONEY THIS SEASON?"
GREG, WE KNOW THERE'S A LOYAL
AUDIENCE THAT -- OR A LOYAL
GROUP OF FOLLOWERS, WHETHER IT
IS THE WINNERS ONLY OR PEOPLE
THAT TAP IN TO THE SHOW EVERY
WEEK, THEY APPEAR IN THE
COMMENTS.
HOW TRANSPARENT ARE THEY GOING
TO BE IN ADMITTING WHICH TEAM OR
PLAYER COST THEM THE MOST AMOUNT
OF MONEY?
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TRANSPARENCY AND WE NEED
PEOPLE TO ADMIT WHO COST THEM
MONEY.
>> CABBIE?
>> YES.
>> LET ME ASK THIS.
LET ME ASK THEM.
HEY, PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE, I
NEED GIFTS.
>> GIFTS OF THE SPECIFIC TEAM OR
PLAYER.
>> OF TEAM OR PLAYER, A TEAM OR
A PLAYER.
>> I'M GOING TO ADD ONE
ACTUALLY.
>> SPECIFIC GIFTS OF A TEAM OR
PLAYER.
LET ME SAY IT ONE MORE TIME.
SPECIFIC GIFTS OF A TEAM OR
PLAYER?
YOU GUYS, FILL THE COMMENTS UP.
LET ME KNOW, WHO LOST YOU THE
MOST MONEY THIS YEAR?
WHO LOST Y'ALL THE MOST MONEY
THIS YEAR.
FILL THE COMMENTS UP, LET US
KNOW.
>> ERIN.
>> CABBIE?
>> YES.
WHO IS IT FOR YOU, ERIN?
>> FOR ME?
IT WAS DEFINITELY --
>> WAS IT THE TEAM OR PLAYER?
>> THE CELTICS, THE PLAYER PROPS
SCREWED ME AT THE LEAD.
WHEN I GET IN A MOOD WHERE I'M
DONE WITH A TEAM, I'M DONE WITH
THEM.
THE CELTICS PLAYER PROPS ARE
CROSSED OFF.
ALSO THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
INCONSISTENT.
I HATE CHASING THEM.
I TALK TRASH ABOUT THEM ALMOST
EVERY MORNING ON MY MORNING
SHOW.
I CAN'T STAND THEM.
I GET IT, THEY'RE IN THE NUMBER
THREE SPOT IN TEERN STHE EASTER
STANDINGS BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE GOOD WHEN BETTING THEM.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HAD BUCKS' SLANDER ON THE GROUP
CHAT.
WHAT DID THE GREEK GOD EVER DO
TO YOU, ERIN?
>> I COULD GO IN.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET ME
STARTED.
>> THIS IS A SAFE SPACE.
YOU ARE WELCOME TO THROW SLANDER
AT ANYBODY, EXCEPT TRISTAN
THOMPSON.
I HAVE BEEN BIT BY CHASING IN
LATE GAMES.
I HAVE LEARNED FROM THE GREAT
KELLY STEWART WHO SAID DON'T
CHASE BAD MONEY WITH GOOD MONEY.
I DID NOT FOLLOW THAT ADVICE.
I ENDED UP LOSING SO MUCH MONEY
WITH THE LAKERS AND GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
I LOVE LIVE BETTING GAMES AND
PLAYER PROPS.
IT WAS THE PLAYER PROPS THAT GOT
ME.
JUST LIKE, ERIN, YOU SAID THE
CELTICS NIPPED YOU IN THE BUTT
WITH PLAYER PROPS.
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS -- YOU KNOW, IT WAS
THREE-POINT OVERS WHETHER IT WAS
J.T.A. OR KELLIE OUBRE JR.
A COUPLE OF TIMES I BET ON
TWO-WATWO
TWO-WAY WIG INSWIGGINS AND THEY
COME THROUGH.
I SAW A LOT OF GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS, SO THE WARRIORS ARE
THE SQUAD THAT COST ME THE MOST
MONEY.
>> G-MONEY, WHO WAS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLAYER ACCORDING TO
THE AUDIENCE AND ACCORDING TO
YOUR FanDUEL ACCOUNT?
>> CABBIE.
>> YES, SIR.
>> I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS ON THE
HANDY DANDY iPAD.
I GOT CHAMP CHEESE.
HE GAVE US THE GIFT OF YOUNG
THUG.
YOU KNOW YOUNG THUG IS FROM
ATLANTA.
I'M CONNECTING THE DOTS.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE ATLANTA
HAWKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, CHAMP CHEESE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I SEE A LOT OF CELTICS.
I GOT OMAR LOW BOW, 49.
ROCKING WITH THE BULLS GAVE US A
GIFT RIGHT HERE.
>> NICE.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> THE BULLS, OKAY.
>> ROCKING WITH THE BULLS.
>> NICE.
>> ANDY LAM, 805, FASTEST LET
DOWN AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR, TALK BING THE MIAMI HEAT.
YOU SEE TYLER HERRO RIGHT THERE.
>> INJURY PLAY, YEAH, YEAH.
>> ANDY LAM, UNFORTUNATELY,
SORRY FOR YOU.
>> NOT A FAN OF THE HAIRCUT.
>> TONGA GONEHO GOT THE
NEW ORLEANS PELICANS.
NEW ORLEANS PELICANS AND ZION.
PUT UP A GIFT RIGHT THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT WAS
MENTIONED.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, DID YOU LOSE
ANY MONEY?
OR DO YOU EVEN BET?
>> CABBIE.
>> AGAIN, WE INVENTED THAT
TOURNAMENT BECAUSE OF YOU, THE
WORST BETTERS OF ALL TIME, AND
IT IS BECAUSE OF YOU, G-MONEY,
THE BET ITER THAT ACTUALLY DOEST
BET.
>> I BET.
>> PROVE IT.
LET'S SEE SOME TICKETS, LET'S
SEE YOUR PHONE.
>> UH.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> OKAY.
I MEAN HERE IS MY PHONE.
>> SHOW US YOUR PHONE.
>> WE COULD SEE -- WE CAN SEE MY
PHONE.
I MEAN -- ANYWAY, THE REAL ONES
KNOW THAT I BET.
LIKE, MAN, CABBIE, YOU THREW ME
OFF.
>> WHAT SQUAD, MY DUDE?
WHAT SQUAD OR TEAM HAS COST YOU
THE MOST MONEY THIS YEAR?
>> I BET.
OH, OH, YEAH.
WE'RE DOING THIS ONE.
IT IS THIS SQUAD.
LIKE, MAN, THEY MEAN A LOT TO
US.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE MY BACK AND I
ALWAYS HAVE THEIR BACK.
THIS SQUAD'S NAME IS WINNERS
ONLY.
>> WHAT?
WAIT.
YOU'RE BLAMING YOUR LOSSES ON
THE AUDIENCE?
>> NO.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO LOSSES.
WINNERS ONLY.
THAT'S -- THAT'S THE MOTTO.
THAT'S THE BRAND.
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO DO WINNERS
ONLY.
IF I HAD TO PICK A TEAM, IF I
HAVE TO PICK A TEAM I WILL PICK
THE WARRIORS.
I WILL BE HONEST, THEY LET ME
DOWN THIS YEAR, BUT I KIND OF
KNEW THAT BUT I ROCK WITH MY
TEAM.
I BET SOME MONEY ON THEM, THEY
LOST ME, THEY LOST ME MONEY.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT, OTHER THAN
THAT, WINNERS ONLY.
PLEASE SAY THE PLEASE.
>> PLEASE SAY THE PLEASE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO WATCH MY TEAM
LOSE AND LOSE ME MONEY AT THE
SAME TIME.
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S THE WORST
FEELING.
I FEEL LIKE I WILL STAY AWAY
FROM MY TEAM WHEN BETTING
SOMETIMES.
>> THAT'S A HEAVY PLAY, ERIN.
WELL DONE.
>> THAT'S A GREAT NUGGET, ERIN.
>> THANK YOU, EVERYBODY, FOR
TAPPING INTO THE GROUP CHAT
PRESENTED BY FanDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE MAY-IN TOURNAMENT STARTS ON
MAY 18th AND GOES UNTIL MAY
21st.
THERE'S TIME TO LOCK IN BETS ON
WHICH TEAMS YOU THINK WILL MAKE
THE PLAYOFFS.
THE GROUP CHAT, THE CHAT
CONTINUES LIVE 24/7 IN "THE
BLEACHER REPORT" APP UNDER THE
SPORTS BETTING STREAM AND THE
COMMUNITY STREAM, AND WE'RE BACK
ON TUESDAY, NEXT WEEK, TO KICK
OFF THE PLAYOFFS ALONGSIDE ERIN
DOAN FROM FanDUEL AND GREG
IVORY, MY NAME IS CABBIE
RICHARDS AND WE ARE LEAVING THE
GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
>> BYE, GUYS.
♪
>> GOOD.
NICE WORK TODAY, ERIN.
NICE WORK.
G-MONEY, GOOD LUCK WITH THE
THREE-BY PIECE.
ARE YOU DOING BOTH GAMES OR JUST
THE FIRST ONE?♪ ♪
>>ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY IN
NEW YORK.
HAVE A